there are quite a few places around the
world one hardly has a chance to access
for example the bottom of the Mariana
Trench or the crater of the Tambora
volcano but there are still more of
these places to be found in the space
one of them is the vicinity of the
remote planet Neptune this celestial
body is four-and-a-half billion
kilometres away from us to get there by
an ordinary rocket would take us about
20 years however there was something
from the earth that was able to approach
this planet and even take a few photos
of it this was the famous Voyager 2
probe which still remains the only
apparatus to have flown by Neptune
Voyager 2 spent just a few months near
the planet but even in that short
timespan
it was able to get a great amount of
valuable information Neptune was the
last big object to be seen by Voyager 2
before the probe entered the heliopause
boundaries and came into interstellar
space but what did the last shots from
Neptune look like before you find out
what it was let's look at the probes
history August the 20th 1977 this is the
day when Voyager 2 left the surface of
the earth 41 years later it was to go
beyond the boundaries of the entire
solar system initially its mission
implied only the exploration of Jupiter
Saturn and their satellites but the
flights trajectory presented the
opportunity of flying by Uranus and
Neptune as well as soon as on July the
9th 1979 Voyager 2 was 71 thousand
kilometers away from Jupiter the probe
also flew by its satellites Europa and
Ganymede
the images received from the spacecraft
gave grounds for putting forward the
hypothesis there being a liquid ocean
under the crust of Europa the
observation of Ganymede showed that it
was covered by a dirty ice crust by the
time two more years had elapsed Voyager
2 was 101 thousand kilometers away from
Saturn the probe flew by its satellites
tethers and Enceladus and transmitted
detailed pictures of their surface
according to initial forecasts that was
supposed to be the end of its mission
but Voyager 2 continued on its course
January the 24th 1986 the spacecraft
approached Uranus and faster to the
distance of 81 thousand kilometers
Voyager 2 sent a number of photos to the
earth the planets satellites as well as
its rings and surface were to be seen in
the pictures it is thanks to them that
two more Uranus's rings were discovered
and the nine already known ones were
studied closer to more years later
Voyager 2 found itself in the vicinity
of the furthermost object of its mission
and past Neptune within forty eight
thousand kilometers on August the 24th
1989 it was able to take unique
photographs of this giant and shoot
Triton its largest satellites
active geezers were discovered and
Triton which came as a big surprise
given the remote position and low
temperature of this celestial body only
21 years after that did the probe cross
the termination shock and dented the
heliopause 11 years on and Voyager 2
passed through this area as well to come
into interstellar space to stay but what
did the last planet seem by Voyager to
look like
many of you will certainly agree that
Nepean rates is practically the most
mysterious planet in the solar system it
is a body closest to Uranus in terms of
its composition it is perceived as a
huge blue planet as a rule and is even
classified as an icy giant Neptune's
atmosphere is similar to that of Jupiter
and is mainly composed of hydrogen and
helium the planetary interior is for the
most part made up of stone and ice the
color blue comes from methane in the
outer layers of the atmosphere Neptune's
diameter earns it the fourth place among
the other planets of the solar system
and it holds the third place in terms of
its mass this planet is 17 times the
size of the earth Neptune is also known
for its dire climate the strongest winds
and the solar system blow in its
atmosphere and according to some
estimates their speed may reach 600
meters per second
a wind of this force would append any
object of average size landed on the
planet's surface the temperature on the
surface of Neptune is close to minus 220
degrees Celsius but if you were to find
yourself there the code and fierce wind
would not be the most drying audio what
is much scarier is that one year on
Neptune would cost you 165 earth years
since the time Neptune was discovered in
1846 just over a year has passed
on this planet so what could buoyed you
to see around that cheerless place the
first pictures taken by Voyager 2 as it
was approaching Neptune were received on
the 23rd of January 1989 when the probe
was 310 million kilometers away from the
planet as the probe got closer the
images revealed formations and Neptune's
atmosphere these three images were
received at a 90 minute interval the
photos allowed scientists to see
atmospheric clouds as was notice a huge
dark spot
the size of the spot
was similar to the Great Red Spot and
Jupiter it should be noted that this
area on Neptune was 10% darker than the
atmosphere surrounding it when Voyager 2
got closer still it was able to see the
planet in color these photos were taken
from the distance of 176 million
kilometers there was a five-hour
difference between them during which
time the planet had rotated a hundred
degrees
the probes next objective was the
closest satellites on July the 3rd 1989
it was able to take a picture of Triton
and capture both Triton and Neptune in
one image the probe kept getting closer
and launched another active series of
picture-taking 35 million kilometers
away from Neptune to capture the nebulae
for closer study apart from the great
dark spot a few dozens of similar
formations were observed in this
contrasting image Voyager 2 managed to
capture thin and bright clouds this
picture made it clear that they floated
much higher than the great dark spot the
next couple of photos was taken at a 17
hour interval and it could be seen that
the great dark spot completed the almost
full turn around the planet
the scientists realized that spots like
these are able to move around Neptune at
the speed of a hundred meters per second
the voyagers images also made it
possible to gauge the wind force which
in some areas reached as much as 700
meters per second which is practically
the sound speed the closest distance of
the probes approached to the cloud layer
of the planet made at 4900 kilometers
the images depict cirrus clouds casting
their shadows on the layer of continuous
clouds underneath
during its flight Voyager 2 was able to
take pictures of several satellites for
example Triton and married having done
that the probe continued on its course
and bid its last farewell to the views
of this planet
the last image taken by Voyager 2 near
Neptune does indeed look like a goodbye
the probe had entered a shadow at the
time that is why just part of the icy
giant can be seen that was the end of
their short acquaintance and Voyager 2
left those parts never to return again
Voyager 2 still remains the only
spacecraft to have reached uranus and
neptune its successful mission was
outstripped only by that of the new
Horizons probe which reached Pluto in
July 2015
Voyager 2 however will always remain a
legend of space exploration
in about 300 years it will reach the
Oort cloud and will sail beyond it only
in 30,000 years it is highly likely that
by that time more than one exploration
mission to Neptune will have been
launched but the achievements of Voyager
two can truly be called a worthy
beginning of this story
[Music]